find the point where they provide you
this function where is it stationary now
you put this table that which else you
remember what's what
good job okay so I have a look at this
this is f the first step in many of
these because it's the geometrical
operations of calculus is I need a
derivative this I need a derivative and
then I can trust some conclusions off it
okay so this F would you like to
differentiate in this one I think
expanding is the way to go right entry
is plug so I'm going to write that as x
squared one you want two numbers you
know come on
by the way think I just guys right you
should never ever ever expand any of
these which are going to become
quadratics just by pairing up terms
because you're so used to doing this is
reverse why don't you take advantage of
that right usually see the expanded
thing and you say I want a pair of
numbers that add to this multiplies to
this well now they give me the pair of
numbers so they add to this and they
multiply to this but just just do that
that is twice as fast okay no regrouping
collectors done okay all right there we
go I've got that what do I do with this
thing what was the point of expanding
yes good so I now say F dash okay now
quick note and some of you guys felt the
pain of this last time right please
please please do not say oh cool I
expanded now I need to differentiate so
I'll just write you love but the number
people in this class who said that so
I'm doing two different things so say
that you're doing two different things
this guy down here is f dash okay now
what are they actually often what's the
point having better
I want the new baby who is zero so I say
now if I want to be proper about this
I'm going to say f of X is stationary
when f of X is
when okay now you might feel like me do
I really have to write like that's
that's like a whole out of Marion like
20 characters like she's got time to
write that well I think you should kind
of make time to do it especially when we
get to more of these difficult
applications of calculus you're going to
be having equations that you see to pop
out of nowhere right you are trying to
communicate that you understand and that
communicates that you know what you're
doing okay and you know why you're about
to bias this as the next line okay it's
not just coming out of nowhere because I
usually notice in my working that f dash
x equals zero is the third line
right that's not understanding that's
just mindlessly going through an
algorithm but this that's the meaning
behind this next line okay so I'm going
to encourage you to write as much as
possible and that's what I'm solving for
I just found if - next right so I will
say ie to X take away C's equals the
zero okay the point here is not enough
focus on equations anymore
you can simply stake in that namely x
equals three have I sold the question I
haven't thank you very much when you
read carefully they're looking for a
point which means they're looking for
coordinates all right so I would say
being them I have this all in function
notation I would say that x equals three
and I would say F of three there no
wising this question did you notice that
F of 3 is equal to 3 take away 2 3 take
away 4 I mean I could have used the
expanded version if I wanted they put
the same but I knew that was gonna give
three take away 2 which is just 1 and 3
take away 4 which is negative 1 ok happy
with that now there are my coordinates
so I would say therefore 3 equals
negative 3 comma negative 1 that's the
point of time stationary ok
now you've got some great calm
confirmation of this because you
actually know it's so important has a
name this is a quadratic what's the name
of the point where it's stationary order
of quadratic most physically it's called
vertex right and of course the vertex
lies on the axis of symmetry of the
parabola which is exactly halfway
between your two roots are you happy you
see how all that your trees feed
together okay so I'm done with that
question anyway any queries you want to
clarify anything this next question has
two parts and it's important that it has
two parts because in some senses
had they not stated it in two parts and
I'm not steady due to two parts I'm
simply saying this is kind of an odd to
say this because you can't be always
decreasing and stationary at the same
time these are actually mutually
exclusive but being phrased to two
questions as two questions mean we're
going to solve it and pray that answer
in two ways so let's begin
after the x equals that what's a way I
can write it so I don't have to
differentiate it as a questions thank
you index form always the preference
okay so there's F let's do F - oh my god
power comes at the phrase the
coefficient and then the power decreases
by one I can rewrite this back like sir
okay and from this I can make some
arguments never stationary so I have a
couple of alternatives I think in this
case because this is such a simple
example because the matter how large X
is or how small X is there's nothing you
can put into this denominator to make
the whole thing zero
did you see that so I would say what
negative one on x squared cannot equal 0
for any value of x right I mean I'm
saying real values but even complex
numbers you're gonna be in trouble so
seeing as this expression here is never
equal zero therefore the derivative is
never equal to zero therefore it is
therefore no stationary it never stops
it never has a derivative is zero I
don't need to make any more arguments
from it that was part of one how are you
part two this is a bit trickier
yes what would you suggest okay so I can
say now be careful by the way x-squared
very very careful x-squared is almost
always almost almost always positive
there is one tiny little spot where
x-squared is in fact is not positive
that's about right x squared is not
always positive
aha but in our case it can't be zero up
here really I should have said X can be
less than zero or X can be greater right
so for those values for those values x
squared is always positive
don't you agree with that so I can say
right in the domain okay namely that guy
up there x squared is always greater
than zero that's a pretty okay back
right there for the reciprocal x squared
like it's it's a positive number and if
you take the reciprocal of a positive
number that's also positive right that's
also positive you haven't just magically
change the sign by turning it upside
down change its value turned on its side
which is the important part of your
argument what do I do with this because
that's not the answer yes exactly
because what I want is not to be
positive and I don't want this I want
that right so I'm going to multiply both
sides by negative 1 which means me with
this on the left hand side with this on
the right hand side and the inequality
has changed around okay see that see you
see how I'm arguing from what I know
there's some very simple facts right and
then deduce - lets have - right and
remember I said I started by saying in
the domain that's everywhere that X can
work for this function right I've heard
I've shown the derivative is less than 0
ok therefore
sex is always decreasing